congratulations to you both this is such
a fun movie and I really really enjoyed
it I want to start with probably the
most important question which what is
your favorite Beanie Baby the snake
no actually I'm sorry the purple monkey
that hits the camera in the in the in
the crash scene
such a good scene yeah and I I really
like uh the ghost Ava's ghost in the
film I I have to say spooky was one of
my favorites too by the end of it
um Damien you have a composing and sort
of music video directing background well
Kristen you've primarily acted as a
screenwriter how did these backgrounds
really help you prepare for directing
your first feature uh on the one hand we
never could have made this without
already knowing what we wanted to make
on the other hand nothing can prepare
you for this and so they didn't
but luckily it was a great opportunity
to um marry our Stu to skill sets into
what we you know we we say all the time
like we never what we made together is
so much better than what either one of
us could have done individually and that
was really very fun to experience
um we have completely different brains
but very similar instincts and so we
managed to meet we just get there in
different directions we get there in
different directions I start from the
end and work towards how do we get to
that she starts from the beginning
yeah so we meet in the middle no I love
that speaking of that I feel like
there's really interesting and sort of
tricky structure with this film because
you jump around obviously with
perspective and also with time I was
curious is was that always going to be
the structure and how did you sort of
ensure that that was going to work
because there's a lot of things to
juggle with that the point of the film
it we hope is it's not the meaning
babies and it's not Tai's story it's the
story of the women and what we found in
the book that we read about the the real
phenomenon was that
um there is an interesting thing that
happened it's it's a crazy thing that
happened but that in its in and of
itself is mostly just a context for us
that it was astonishing how the same
cycle kept happening through through
this story that that
um this really Universal cycle the
female relationship to the American
dream keeps happening and we wanted to
tell the the have all three women on the
same emotional roller coaster ride and
and if we had told it linearly over the
course of these two decades it would
have just been three short stories or it
would have been Ty's story about gaining
wealth and that wasn't interesting to us
what was interesting to us was that over
and over again this same cycle keeps
happening so we it was important from
the very beginning to structure it so
that you would feel that same ride yeah
absolutely I think that really shines
through
um there's a quote that Robbie says that
I feel like really relates to this film
which is but it's the perfect time to
sell a little joy and I feel like this
this is so joyful but it also doesn't
shy away from obviously like the darker
sort of harder themes how did you sort
of try and establish that tone where you
are balancing the raw truth of it but
also make a really fun watch experience
we're so glad that's how it comes across
that is uh the only thing we ever want
to make and consume is a sort of mixture
of joy and meaning you know where you
are exploring things that you really
care about but you're having a good time
with it too we talked we sometimes talk
about this movie as being
like a funeral for the American dream
but a New Orleans style second line
parade through the French Quarter type
of funeral you know where there's
there's some Darkness there's
dysfunction in the story but it's also a
party and for us that was our north star
from the beginning that's totally what
we the only way we wanted to make it
it's such a small Bullseye yeah so
everything was structured around it just
because that's the only thing we know
how to make and so we're happy if that
worked and that's largely because we're
like we're too tired at the end of the
day to watch something that is that is
really heavy and painful even if we want
to get into those serious things and
we're also too tired at the end of the
day to watch something that's super
joyful but feel like we wasted our time
and we're not getting any meaning out of
it and it's just
it's what I've loved in pop music and
what I've loved in podcasts it's like
there's the the those times when you
really can fall in love with something
because it's friendly and you love it
and it can speak to you seriously like
that's the that's the truly like you
said the North Star for us and um we're
so lucky we found it in this thing like
neither of us cared about Beanie Babies
growing up and and no disrespect anyone
but we basically still don't it's just
it's just that like it's a it's a bubble
of color and joy and and absurdity like
really truly crazy little facts about
the weirdest things and that the the
first ever
consumer-facing website was made by a
first generation or I guess second
generation
immigrant child who is
uh working as a intern and never got
paid more than minimum wage like these
that's such a dark dark thing in such a
bright bright bubble and it is
um that was what was so it was the Jews
to this in the first place yeah
yeah and you spoke
of bright um it is and
about these women's like very subtle but
very clear sort of color Journeys was so
interesting to me can you talk a little
bit about establishing um the color in
those colored Journeys well we we
thought early on about how about two
things one we didn't want this to be
um a Pastiche or a cliche of the 80s and
90s it was we didn't want to go into
that sort of like the garish colors of
the time and make you feel like oh
everybody's wearing a Walkman you know
like the the we wanted it to be a
universal and and slightly more
organized and perfect than real life um
you know that that it wouldn't want
anyone to notice that just have it be
slightly more filmic and big just have
it feel like a fable of the time gone by
um but also we were we really wanted to
differentiate the three storylines that
without going like without having aspect
ratios I didn't want it to take you out
of the story we wanted it to feel a part
of it and we wanted that the the the the
the editing between them to accelerate
so that we knew that by the time we got
to the end of this we'd be jumping
around the storyline so fast that we
couldn't have it be like this one's on
16 mil and this one's like it couldn't
be really ridiculous like that so if we
gave them all the same level of
intensity but really restricted their
palettes so you're not going between
different color treatments like
different cameras you're just her world
is just always red and the different
things around it her world's always blue
and the things around it so and of
course we chose primaries we have red
yellow blue so they together they build
the whole universe but you only see it
one one angle at a time and we had a
massive spreadsheet of the breakdown of
the whole movie with each character with
all the colors assigned to it going all
the way through and luckily ready and
Willy and collaborators and our
production designer and our
cinematographer and our costume designer
not something they normally run across
apparently like you don't normally show
up to a question meeting with a giant
spreadsheet going like okay in this
scene you're allowed to use teal yellow
and light purple nothing else yeah
oh but they hopped on board and it
really worked it made us yeah attending
to detail I think really shines through
um thank you so much for your time I
really can't wait for everyone to see
the movie thanks so much thank you take
care